today I'm going to be ranking reddit's
top skincare tips I'm going to be talking
about the science behind them if there's
any and then ranking them on this scale
I know it's a bit of a cliche that news sites
steal content ideas from Reddit but since I
donated thousands of hours to modding it in
the past it's not as bad if I do it I think
hi I'm Michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
and big fan of cheap skincare tips
like I said I was a moderator on
Reddit's skincareaddiction forum
for about four years so I've seen a
lot of these tips before and now I'm
seeing a lot of them again being
recycled on places like tiktok
how I got this list it's not the most
robust methodology I searched Reddit
using Google because that is what you do
I looked up skincare tips and skincare
hacks and then I went through the top 50
search results for each of those and I
looked for posts that had over a hundred
upvotes then I took the top 10 comments
of those tallied them up and then got the
top 10 and here they are in reverse order
this time with my ranking I'm gonna
make it clear this is how how much of
a difference I think they'll make for
people in general so if one of these
tips will work really well for a tiny
group of people I will talk about that
but it's probably not going to score that
well on this rubric so keep that in mind
number 10 is slugging this actually
showed up a lot less than I expected
slugging is when you put on a really thin
layer of Vaseline or petroleum jelly as
your final step at night you put it on over
the rest of your skincare and then you go to
sleep and you end up shiny a bit like a
slug which is where that name came from
back when the name slugging was
invented this was when snail was
also really popular in Reddit probably
around 2014-ish so it seemed to make
sense that this would also be like I
don't know another mollusc related name
your skin is more permeable at night there is
higher transepidermal water loss and what that
means is you have lots of water evaporating
that means your skin can dry out more easily
and so you end up wanting to trap in
water more which this works really well
for because petrolatum is the gold standard
occlusive it's really good at sealing water
the other thing that happens is
your skin can get dried out and
itchy and tight and again this helps prevent that
on top of that more hydrated skin can
also let in some skincare ingredients
a bit more easily into the skin so this can also
have an effect of helping your skincare
ingredients penetrate a bit more deeply
slugging went viral again on tiktok not
that long ago it's very weird being a bit
of a dinosaur in internet years because
this seems like such an ancient trend
to me and of course even before reddit people's
grandmas were doing this so yeah not a new hack
I do like this because it is a very cheap
hack and a lot of people do have a jar of
Vaseline lying around that they
will never get to the bottom of
so it is something that I think most
people can try without too much risk
some people have asked me about the
environmental impact and it should
be pretty low because petroleum jelly is a
byproduct of oil as long as we are digging
up petroleum to burn in cars then petroleum
jelly is going to be quite cheap because it
doesn't require a lot of extra resources
to make I've talked about this before in
my video on environmental claims so
check that out if you're interested
the downsides of this is first off your skin
gets really sticky and your hair and cat fur
and dust just gets stuck to your face
it's pretty annoying a bit off-putting
it can also potentially push irritants
deeper into your skin again if it's
pushing active ingredients it is also
pushing other things as well so that
can potentially make your skin care a bit
too much for you but otherwise I think it
is definitely worth a try for most people
so I'm going to put that up here in yes
less is more or you don't need 10 steps I
think this is a very good tip there are a
lot of products out there that don't really have
proven benefits and a lot of skincare products
overlap in what they do so if you're using a
whole bunch of things there's probably something
not really necessary in there that you can cut
out and you can save time and money and probably
also prevent freaking out your skin too much if
you have sensitive skin then the more stuff you
use the higher the risk of using something that
might interact with your skin in a bad way and
by bad way I don't really mean like permanent
damage it's probably more just like irritation
there are also a lot more multifunctional products
out there these days so you can probably cut down
on the number of products you're using and I think
there is a lot of mindless consumerism going on
people get excited over products that they see on
social media they start buying it before thinking
about whether it actually fits into their
skincare routine in a way that makes sense
also when people do this they tend to introduce
way too many products to their skin at the same
time like you get the parcel you open it and then
you just slap everything on your skin as well as
freaking out your skin that also means that you
can't really tell what is actually working this is
something that we use a lot in experimental design
in science we control the variables that means
we keep everything constant except for one thing
which we change and that means if we only change
one thing then if we have something changing in
our skin we have an outcome changing there is a
higher chance of that thing that we changed
having caused that outcome so I don't think
explain that very well but basically if you
change one thing and one thing changes then the
link between those is going to be a lot stronger
you can make a much stronger conclusion about it
anyway at the same time I don't entirely
subscribe to the whole everything other
than three products is a waste of time and
money some people's skin can benefit from
extra steps and having extra bits in their
routine some people do also just have fussier
skin and there aren't two perfectly formulated
products on the market that address all their
needs they have to kind of fudge it a
bit more with more different products
so essentially everyone's skin is different
I highly recommend working out your own skin
needs and concerns and then narrowing it
down that way and not getting swept up in
hype about products if you want a guide to
working out your skid needs and concerns
and figuring out a basic routine that works
for your skin you can check out my ebook so
I'm going to put that in solid I think
if it says sometimes less is more then
I would agree with that a bit more but yeah
it's not something that works for everyone
on to number eight which is sleep on your back so
there are two main reasons that people recommend
this number one is something called sleep lines
sleep lines are a special type of wrinkle that
are vertical the reason we get wrinkles is it's a
combination of skin quality and repeater creasing
with skin quality it's stuff like how much
collagen you have how thick your skin is the
thinner and more uneven it is the more likely
it is to form a wrinkle with the same sorts of
forces the other part of wrinkles is repeated
creasing so things like crow's feet expression
lines on like your forehead and between your
brows that's why getting Botox injections can
help with wrinkles because it stops your muscles
from repeatedly creasing those things and kind of
etching that temporary wrinkle that you
get in motion into a permanent crease
so as well as expression lines we also sleep
for about eight hours a day and our heads are
heavy so if you're kind of smushing your
face and sideways or like frontwards into
your pillow every day with the whole weight of
your head then you can can get these creases
on your face these creases tend to go up
and down on your face and they don't line
up with any other sort of expression so it has
to pretty much come from sleeping in particular
positions so sleeping on your back is a way
of avoiding this and there are products like
pillows that purposely try to make you sleep
on your back there's also a sort of practical
aspect which is just not getting all your stuff
on your face onto your pillow and vice versa so
you're keeping your skincare working on
your skin and not working on your pillow
your pillow also stays cleaner for
longer and you don't have extra dirt
and I don't know hair oil and sweat from
four days ago going back onto your face
so this can make a big difference for
some people who have acne for example
the problem with this tip though is you also
don't want to sacrifice your quality of sleep
some people can get used to a new sleep
position pretty easily some people cannot
for example if you have sleep apnea issues
then you might not be able to sleep on your
back without having a really disturbed sleep
so this is a bit of a your mileage will vary
kind of tip I wouldn't recommend this to
absolutely everyone but if you are worried
about sleep lines or if you are finding that
your skin is getting aggravated by getting
gunk from your pillow onto it then this is
probably worth a try this will go somewhere
between meh and solid I think I'm going to
put it in solid and I might reconsider it
number seven is oily and acne prone skin can need
moisturizer this one I really like because it
applies to me this was actually one of the things
that got me into skincare in the first place I had
oily and acne prone skin I went for years trying
to find good solutions a lot of that involved
putting alcohol on my skin and just drying out my
skin a lot then at some point I started putting
on glycerin-based moisturizer on my skin and
rosehip oil and that made a huge difference my
skin actually improved a whole bunch and it seemed
really counter-intuitive at the time but now it
makes perfect sense because oil and water are
not the same thing if your skin produces enough
of its own oil that oil is actually first off not
very good at sealing and water and secondly the
oil from your skin is not exactly the same as the
oil that you're putting on in skincare products
your skin oil oxidizes easily and when it
oxidizes it can harden and then start clogging
up your pores it can also irritate your skin
so if you're putting on other oils onto your
skin it can change the composition of oils
on your skin overall one of the reasons this
makes such a big difference is that water is
really important for your skin it signals to
your skin to do certain things for example if
your skin is more hydrated then it actually
exfoliates itself a bit more easily so a lot
of people who have oily acne prone skin they
might try to dehydrate their skin because
they think that their skin is oily it needs
less oil and then what happens is your
skin doesn't exfoliate itself properly it
doesn't desquamate properly is the technical term
instead it starts coming off in big chunky flakes
this tip won't work for everyone obviously it is
only really for people who have oily skin who were
drying out their skin in the first place and some
moisturizers can possibly make things worse as
well so this is a bit of a niche tip again but I
think it is useful I'm going to put it in probably
oh I'm gonna have to put it in may even though
I like this tip a lot just because it doesn't
really apply to everyone but it does apply to a
lot of people who tend to be on skincare addiction
because that subreddit is mostly for younger
people who tend to have more acne problems
number six is use hyaluronic acid or moisturizer
on damp skin this one is a bit complex where this
comes from is humectants humectants are one of
the three main types of moisturizers they're
the ones that work by holding onto water
so they latch onto water and that slows it
from evaporating now there is all this stuff
from the internet where it says if you have
more humid weather then it's going to grab
water from the atmosphere and I don't know
drag it down to your skin but if you have a
dry climate then it is going to pull water
out of your skin and dry it out none of
this is really supported by the evidence
everyone has trans epidermal water loss which
is water evaporating through the top layers
of the skin from the epidermis so basically
your insides are like 70% water and then it
lowers as it gets up so yeah water is constantly
evaporating off your skin that's probably the main
source of where the humectants get their water
they just grab onto this water as it goes past
now in a hyaluronic acid product or
moisturizer you're going to have a
lot of water generally it is going to be
upwards of 60% water probably closer to
80% most of the time this is more than enough
water to saturate all the water binding spots
on hyaluronic acid or any other humectant in
your product so adding extra water is really
not necessary it's already holding on to the
maximum water if you add extra water it's
just going to be floating around away from the
humectant it's not going to make a difference
but it does feel like it's making
a difference and I think one of the
main reasons is that your skin just has more
water at the start your skin is just wetter
so it feels immediately more hydrated rather
than having to wait for that trans epidermal
water loss to start getting trapped by
whatever occlusives for example that
you have in your moisturizer and this extra
water can take a while to evaporate so yeah
your skin does feel a bit more hydrated at the
start but if you went off and tested your skin
maybe an hour or two hours afterwards I don't
think there would be that much of a difference
one situation where I do think this can make
a big difference is if you are coming out of
the shower you've been in the shower your
skin has been soaking in water for a fair
bit if you put on moisturizer immediately
that can make a difference compared to
putting on moisturiser 15 minutes afterwards
and that's because water does actually make
skin more permeable it's kind of ironic
you're adding more water and that water
makes your skin lose water more easily so if
you quickly slap on an occlusive when your
skin is still wet then that just sort of slows
down that evaporation that boosted evaporation
anyway long story short if you like having extra
water then use it if you don't like using extra
water don't feel like you have to because I don't
know your moisturizers are stealing your water
I'm gonna put that one in meh
it's entirely a preference thing
tip number five use less actives or exfoliants
or rotate through them and use more soothing
and hydrating products this is pretty similar
to the less is more tip I think people do tend
to do a bit too much to their skin especially
when they're starting out with skin care when
they're in that sort of excited phase when
they're just buying things and slapping stuff
onto their face and trying to like throw
everything up the wall to see what sticks
and i think this tends to happen a lot especially
with people who are using harsher products to try
to attack their acne they're kind of thinking if i
attack my skin then i can beat it into submission
but the problem with that is of course irritation
and inflammation can actually contribute to acne
a lot of people also overdo it with exfoliants
and that means you thin down your skin barrier
a bit too much those dead layers of cells on
the top of your skin those are meant to protect
the rest of your skin the living layers
from the environment if you thin it too
much then your skin does really tend to
suffer it gets irritated more easily it
gets inflamed it gets itchy it's just not
really doing its job properly and it takes
a while to recover as well you have to sort
of just bench your skin for two three weeks
i have a video with my friend hannah on how
how to recover after doing this and again
like i mentioned before hydration can also
help with exfoliation you don't have to just
use harsh exfoliants so i'm probably going
to put this into solid i think it is a tip
that will work for most people most people
should probably try every once in a while
to just slow down on their products and see
if that actually makes a difference to their
skin because if it does then you're
going to save a lot of time and money
next tip is change your pillowcases more i kind of
talked about this before in the sleeping
on your back part this is all about having
a dirty pillowcase and how that can
sometimes contribute to people's acne
again acne is probably the most common
skin problem on skincare addiction
there was even a product that was dedicated to
this idea it was like a pillowcase and then on
top there were like layers of pillowcase materials
so you could use one each day and then like peel
off the top layer chuck that in the laundry have a
fresh layer and then after can't remember how many
days you would get to the bottom and then by then
your old sheets were coming back out of the wash
i've also seen people recommending putting
t-shirts onto your pillow as like extra pillowcase
covers i think this tip can work really well for
some people but again it is a subset of people
a lot of acne does come from factors other than
just having dirty stuff on your face so because
it is such a limited technique i'm probably
going to put it into i'm going to put it into meh
tip number three is avoid saturated sugars
and oils or cut out dairy or heal your gut
generally diet and food advice i am really
not a fan of dietary advice on the internet
you can see that all of these are actually
pretty restrictive like saturated sugars and
oils are in a lot of foods dairy is often a
lot of people's diet and healing your gut is
just very general i think if you start looking
up healing your gut you end up down some very
weird rabbit holes so if you suddenly start
following these really restrictive eating
rules you can end up with a really imbalanced
diet and it can even lead to eating disorders
i've even seen some dermatologists mostly
younger dermatologists giving the sort
of dietary advice on places like tiktok
from talking to a lot of dermatologists
if they're a bit more older and experienced
they tend to have seen some of these issues
in their patients already so they are
a lot more cautious about giving this
sort of advice and some dermatologists
have themselves been affected by it
and there is some evidence that eating
lower GI foods can potentially help
with acne and cutting out certain
types of dairy but it does need a
lot of caveats because the evidence for
diet influencing your skin is just so
much less solid than for things like
products and particular ingredients
I talked about this in a video collaboration I
did with Dr Anjali Mahto and she's also written
some articles on it that you can check out
I think the way that the British Association
of dermatologists phrased this advice is
really quite good it's possibly written
by Anjali basically what they say is if you've
noticed that a particular food might be causing
changes in your skin then try skipping that
particular food for a while and observe what
happens to your skin then introduce it
back into your diet and see what happens
so notice that this is about a specific food
and not like a whole food group or a whole
chunk of your diet and also it's time limited so
it's like guiding you how to do this experiment
on yourself and not just saying avoid all of
this stuff which is probably not that healthy
so I'm gonna put this in no because I
think it does probably introduce more
problems than it solves in general for
people but if you are going to try it
make sure there is a limit in terms of
the foods involved just try to minimize
that as well as minimizing the time
period that you're going to try it
tip number two is use tretinoin or use
retinol pretty straightforward advice I
think this is really good advice retinoids
are just a really good all-rounder class of
ingredients they tackle so many skin concerns
if you have gone towards skin care for a reason
then it is probably going to tick off one
of your reasons they can increase collagen
which reduces wrinkles they can increase
skin turnover which reduces acne it also
smooths out your skin and helps reduce pigment
it also normalizes pigment production it also
acts as an antioxidant so yeah they also
have the most evidence for them helping
with a whole bunch of things some people's
skin can't really tolerate it very well but
these days there are so many products on the
market there are much more gentle ones there
are ones that are formulated specifically for
people who have issues with irritation so I'm
pretty sure there is a retinoid out there for
you I'm going to put this up all the way at yes
finally tip number one I don't think this comes
as a surprise to anyone it's just wear sunscreen
again this is really good advice it is something
that can help with pretty much all skin conditions
UV contributes to everything it contributes to
wrinkles it contributes to increased pigment
it also increases inflammation which then
indirectly leads to acne as well as making
a whole bunch of other skin conditions
worse like rosacea chances are you are
using skincare to try to address one of these
things that UV does so you are kind of wasting
your money on skin care if you're not also
protecting your skin from further damage by UV
I do find that Reddit sometimes goes
overboard with the sun avoidance back
when I was moderating I would come across
a lot of posts that were like if you can
see sunlight you need to wear sunscreen
people would ask questions like do I need
to wear sunscreen to bed if I can see a
little bit of sunlight peeking out from
around my curtains I think that sort
of hyper focus can be a bit unhealthy
and this is one of the reasons why I made this
video talking about how much sun you get indoors
i think in general people tend to see things
in black and white so sun versus no it's also
a thing in clean beauty like does this have
parabens yes or no does this ingredient cause
cancer yes or no but when you start looking
at things like dose how much you're getting
how much UV how much parabens then you can
start to see what does and doesn't make a
difference and of course this changes depending
on your skin as well and your susceptibility to
some but there are very very few people in
the world who are sun sensitive enough to
have to wear sunscreen to bed but yeah wearing
sunscreen definitely belongs on the top tier
so those were my rankings of reddit's top
skincare tips let me know if you agree let
me know if there's an obvious tip that's missing
from here I've been really enjoying doing these
ranking videos because they're a bit more chatty
we can go into a bit more deep discussion about
things and not just focus on technical stuff
which is a lot of my other videos so let me
know if you have any other ideas for ranking
videos If you enjoyed this video click like
and subscribe there are more skincare videos
popping up around me so check those out as well